what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and of
course spider-man no way home the first
teaser trailer that we got for
spider-man no way home broke the record
for most viewed trailer in a hour period
beating avengers end game to do that
which is quite impressive but now it has
some competition and that competition is
its official second trailer which would
be a full trailer they surprisingly gave
us a lot in the teaser trailer i
actually didn't think they were gonna
show any of the multiversal sinister six
at all let alone show doc ock right up
in front yet they did and it makes you
wonder what exactly are they going to
show in the full trailer the official
full-length trailer that is supposed to
give us the entire plot of the movie you
just have to think if this was the
teaser what is the full thing and how do
you go bigger and make people even more
excited about the film well according to
some reports today it looks like marvel
and sony might have figured that out and
we have some news on when to possibly
expect that second trailer to get here
as well along with how long the actual
movie could actually be and if you'd
like to follow spider-man no way home
including the release of its other
trailers be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos now i
want to start this by talking about the
run time of spider-man no way home
because right now there is a report
going around that says how long the
movie is actually going to be according
to the twitter account mcu underscore
source the spiderman no way home film is
going to be 2 hours and 37 minutes long
now i want to address this because this
is in no way a confirmation that the
movie is indeed going to be that long
after all right now the film is still
being put together the official run time
might not be set yet and they didn't
report a source for this report which is
understandable in some cases sometimes i
get told information that i tell to the
public but i can't exactly tell who my
source is because they could get in
trouble but as of right now i'm going to
take this as a rumor especially since
when films get completed their run time
can change but if this is somewhat true
or near what we could expect from the
movie's runtime it's going to be a
pretty long movie which i'm entirely
here for and i actually think the movie
does need quite a bit of time especially
if you're going to involve so many
different characters and they're going
to come from different universes
especially if you consider that the
majority of the people that are gonna go
watch it aren't exactly like us they're
not on the internet every day looking up
videos looking up leaks there's a lot of
people that are going to go into this
movie blind simply because they love
spider-man so for those people who
haven't done that much research like us
they're probably going to need some
explaining when it comes to the
multiverse and when it comes to variants
so i personally think that a two and a
half hour run time would be great for
everybody because i could seriously sit
down and watch like a four hour movie
but now let's talk about that second
spider-man no way home trailer and this
trailer from what i'm hearing and the
rumors going around out there this
trailer sounds like it could break the
previous trailer's record specifically
because of what it could possibly show
to the world and that of course is the
three spider-man and the whole entire
sinister six and what's interesting is
we still don't actually know who the
sixth villain is it kind of makes me
think that it could be ned as hobgoblin
but more on that in a bit now we have a
few people reporting that the second
trailer for spider-man no way home is
indeed going to give us a shot of the
three spider-man tom holland spider-man
toby maguire spider-man and andrew
garfield spider-man so let's start with
the first report that is coming from big
screen leaks who is a verified account
on twitter who have dropped accurate
information about spider-man no way home
in the past they tweeted the other day
so right now i hear that the plan is for
toby and andrew to be in the second
spider-man no way home trailer and
they'll be the money shot i would say
that the money shot in the first trailer
was definitely doc ox tentacles and then
the reveal of doc ock himself saying his
iconic line hello peter
hello peter
that was definitely it the confirmation
of the spider verse and we got that
right after we saw a pumpkin bomb and a
laugh which did sound a lot like willem
dafoe's
be careful what you wish for and a
pumpkin bomb explosion this 10 seconds
right here did confirm that spider-man
no way home will be a spider-verse movie
however we haven't seen the other
spider-man but even without seeing the
other spider-man this trailer broke the
record for most viewed trailer in 24
hours so if the money shot of the next
trailer is going to be the three
spider-man together that could
definitely break the record now of
course they're not going to show them
the entire time they're probably going
to spend a lot of time talking about the
villains and the multiverse in the
official trailer we need more about the
actual plot of the movie and the actual
main plot of the movie is that the
multiverse is kind of breaking or
bursting into madness if you will and
villains from other spider-man universes
are starting to come into tom holland's
universe that's when they're kind of
going to explain that doc ock the green
goblin sandman they're from the sam
raimi universe tobey maguire's universe
and then we're going to have electro and
the lizard come from the amazing
spider-man andrew garfield universe this
will have to be explained in the trailer
to the public they're going to have to
really tell them what's going on true
funny story like a day after the
spider-man no way home trailer came out
i had a buddy call me and he's like 55
years old and he says hey i just watched
the new spider-man trailer can you kind
of explain it to me because it looks
like they're running out of ideas and
i'm like what then i explained it to him
i explained the spider-verse and all
three spider-man showing up together and
he was like yeah are they just running
out of ideas that they just got to put
them all together now and my mind was
kind of blown by that statement but he's
the perfect example of somebody who is
going to need some explaining on what is
happening and it sounds like that's kind
of what's going to be happening in the
trailer thankfully and according to
another update account spider.fan1962
the main trailer is going to focus on
the sinister six it's going to show us
more about the multiverse and apparently
it's actually going to show charlie cox
in the trailer and then the report also
finishes with it's also going to show
the first live-action spider-verse
footage which technically we have
already gotten the spider-verse consists
of more than just the actual spider-man
in them the villains make up the
spider-verse as well and like i
mentioned before the fact that
spider-man's identity is going to be
erased and nobody is going to know that
peter parker is indeed spider-man makes
me believe that ned isn't going to know
he's spider-man and if they're pegging
spider-man to be a killer perhaps ned
won't actually like spider-man in this
film he'll like his buddy peter but not
spider-man and perhaps he becomes
hobgoblin somehow now i myself admit
that this is a pretty out there theory
and all it would probably take for this
to not happen is for peter to simply say
hey i'm spider-man we went through a lot
together but doctor strange erased her
memory but it's curious that marvel is
kind of keeping the secret so well under
wraps of who this sixth villain is we've
heard like zero leaks about this at all
and let's be honest this movie isn't
exactly known for keeping it secret so
it must be somebody pretty special but
back to this report that is coming from
spider.fan1962 one final thing they say
is that the trailer is going to come
after the 22nd of october not before
that and this date actually kind of
lines up with what the studio would want
to do it's a couple of months after the
release of the first teaser trailer and
it's a couple of months before the movie
comes out the timing for that pretty
much lines up that's typical timing of
when they release their trailers because
you have to also keep in mind that
they're probably going to show like a
thousand tv spots between the official
trailer and the actual release of the
movie seriously during spider-man fire
from home they released a new tv spot
like every day and they're doing that
right now for shang qi so i'm definitely
expecting that so hopefully we should be
getting the trailer in about a month and
a half and from what it sounds like the
possibility of seeing the other two
spider-man appear in the trailer is
actually looking pretty good i
personally heard before that they're not
going to show them in the promotions
until the latter half of the marketing
but i guess this official trailer could
be considered the latter half of the
marketing they didn't show them in the
first they could show them in a second
now we'll have to wait and see but if
you want to stay up to date on all of
these updates be sure to subscribe and
hit that notification bell be sure to
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]
you